[Music]
foreign
otes final entry time has been frozen
for an unknown length of time with no
time to lose I began tunneling Through
Time In Search of fry and Lila only to
find them suffering from a case of
extreme old horrified I offered to reset
the universe to the instant Before Time
stopped they could be young once more
still grotesquely ugly but young what do
you say you want to go around again
I do
[Music]
did someone switch the universe off and
on it feels like we got rebooted ah why
is my beer stale
I'm sharing backwards with friends well
whatever happened the important thing is
it will never ever happen again
Robert yeah I'm just yanking your ass
we're back baby
[Music]